[Music]
welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Dean Karlan a professor of economics
at Yale University and president and
founder of innovations for poverty
action IPA is a research and policy
nonprofit that discovers and promotes
effective solutions to global poverty
problems since its founding in 2002 IPA
has worked with over 400 leading
academics to conduct more than 600
evaluations in 51 countries this
research has informed hundreds of
successful programs that now impact
millions of individuals worldwide today
we talk with Professor Carlin about a
program he designed to raise ultra poor
households out of extreme poverty to a
more stable State welcome professor
Carlin hi great to be here let's begin
with an overview of the program that you
developed tell us about it sure so one
one slight correction just for the
record is I didn't design the program
okay what the you know one of the
questions we get a lot in in this space
both and both and I say this both within
academia but also certainly when I'm
talking with people outside of academia
is so what's the answer
what's the you know what's the cause of
poverty or what's the solution and the
reality is you know there isn't one
single solution and the problem with
poverty the what got us here in this
first place is a multitude of different
factors mm-hmm
now that can be talked about at a grand
level at a country level but what this
program is doing is trying to take that
way of thinking at a micro level at the
household level and saying what are the
issues at the household that might keep
a household in a track so that they just
can't escape that poverty trap and it's
just it's a self-fulfilling trap and so
the the program says well what if the
problem is many things and so the issue
with other ideas that have been put
forward in the past like microcredit or
a training program or even just a simple
cash transfer program is that it's only
getting one thing at a time
mm-hmm just taking one issue dealing
with
that but when you have all these other
issues you you don't get out of the trap
these other things still bind and they
still hit and they make it so you're not
as effective with the one thing that is
being done so this program which is
called the graduation program is its
name that some people gave it says let's
do six things let's do them all at once
and let's make a big push at the
household level with this idea that if
we do this and we see this nice
short-run blip up do we see it in the
long run does it sustain itself do we
see people actually kind of out of this
trap so the six things that it does are
at the heart is a productive asset buy
productive asset I mean something that
generates income okay so it might be for
goats it might be beekeeping in Ethiopia
it was a cow in India usually it's an
animal but in some cases it's something
that's not an animal but it is an asset
an asset that is given to the household
not not lent usually around two to three
hundred dollars of value they also
provide consumption support some food so
that the immediate thing you don't do
when you get those goats is slaughter
one of them to eat it and instead you
rear them so that they can have kids and
on sugar and starch anything anytime
access to a savings account training in
and whatever that asset is and how to
rear it properly and have a sustainable
income source well we call life coaching
which is a little bit nebulous and took
on different forms in the way it's
implemented it's basically consists of a
weekly household visit from the
nonprofit that is implementing the
program or it could be government that
implements this as well to work with the
household both to identify issues
they're having and make a plan what are
the steps you need to take to get from A
to Z and and then a weekly visit to kind
of work through those issues with the
household and access to a savings
account I think yes ready and then
there's one more a little bit of Health
intervention it might be deworming pills
it might be some access to clean water
it's usually not enough where that alone
is thought of as a linchpin of the
program no doubt they're identifying
some health issues and able to provide
some sort of form so it's all these
things at once is basically the program
okay and what countries are you working
in so when we started this program it
had already started a bit in bang
- before us and we saw some early
results there that looked very promising
which is part of what got us excited
about this being something to test one
of the divides that we have are the
problems within academia I would say is
that we don't have enough incentives to
do replication - to see what are you
know let's not just do it one place and
and then think that we answered some
grand question for the world let's do it
in many places and let's try to start
understanding something more concrete
about the bounds with which something is
going to work so Ford Foundation and
this group called C gap which is a donor
consortium that's housed at the World
Bank approached us to say you know
here's this interesting program that
we've been familiar with what do you
think of the idea of doing this in six
places and so that's basically what we
did it took a long time to get the six
all together but implement this in
Honduras Peru Ghana Ethiopia India and
Pakistan okay
and so the evaluation that we were able
to do testing this basic idea in
implementation across these six places
was able to move much faster into policy
because we do find bottom line is the
answer is very positive we do find
successful outcomes okay
and these outcomes persisted all three
years after the assets are transferred
there's a lot more to learn about how to
make it better man but the overall
message was very powerful and and having
the six made it part of what made that
message powerful being able to go into
policy conversations going no no no no
no we're not just taking this one study
from one place and claiming like voila
it's everywhere we did it in six and and
that and that gave us a lot more
confidence and and and grounding and
there's six very different countries
there's six very different countries
there are there are some common aspects
to all of them in terms of the way it
was implemented and first of all the
program was designed to be very similar
although there are adaptations that are
natural that have - you know it's cows
in India but it's not cows in Honduras
right there all were done in rural areas
which is important if one wants to think
about this approach in an urban setting
probably a different set of issues need
to be dealt with and so it would
a bit different the theory might be the
same of these kind of multiple
constraints all interacting needing to
be a bit holistic about how you work on
these issues at the household level
we're predominantly where are these
households who are the poorest I mean I
had read a statistic there are a billion
people who are living on a dollar and a
quarter a day so are they predominantly
in rural areas or in cities so you do
you do have a lot of ultra poverty in
the cities and it looks very different
these studies were all done in in rural
areas and one of the things that these
studies were doing in the very beginning
is the intake process to identify it
wasn't the study doing this as much as
the design in the program is that the
the intake process to be eligible for
the program first the first step was a
participant it's called a participatory
wealth ranking which is basically a
community coming together and talking
about the issues of poverty in their
community and identifying who which
households are the poorest Wow and so a
lot of other programs which have
historically aimed or made arguments
about reaching the poorest like
microcredit have typically not actually
reached the poorest they've reached poor
households but but there's actually a
tranche below where they often will
reach that are not helped by things like
microcredit and so this program is
trying to reach to - to those the the
only real filter that does weed out some
of the poorest would be that if you're
going to transfer be keeping assets
which you know hides and things like
this to help a household in rural
Ethiopia get started with a beekeeping
business they have to have the physical
capabilities to do that and you know so
realistically if a household if the
members are too old or sick there's
other issues that need to be done in if
I'm a humanitarian perspective but it's
not gonna be helpful to hand them a
livelihood that they're not actually
physically going to be able to do so so
those people are often excluded from the
program is it's been rolled out and then
other other programs hopefully out there
how who do you have working with the
families do you do you pick people who
are already living in the countries to
you know train them and then evaluate
them
that way so there's just surfers though
there's a there's a clear separation
which is important you as much as
possible between the implementing
parties in the research so that the
research is managed by IPA for all of
the field operations an IPA has invested
a lot historically in all the different
countries we work to develop capacity in
the country with local Nationals who are
able to manage the fieldwork manage the
surveying and and you know and promote
from from from within in that way and
that's important both for the quality of
the work we're doing the stability of
the work we're doing and also so that
the work itself has that kind of impact
on on the education in the system and
the capacity within country because we
see that some of our alumni who worked
with us and are off doing other things
in government and we can see the impact
from our work in that way and it's
exciting to see that so that's that's on
the research side the the ones that are
actually working with the households
that's in each case as a different
answer for who did that and usually it
was in it was a local NGO was basically
partnered with in Honduras and Peru was
planned international that then operated
on the ground in Ghana we identified a
local nonprofit called Presby a Greek
that we had worked with in the past and
had a really good set of field staff
were very you know understand the issues
of the households they're dealing with
and and they're they've taken on many
different projects that are a bit
different they're not just agricultural
and so they were a good partner in
Pakistan was actually four different
nonprofits in India it was a nonprofit
arm of a microcredit organizations each
one has a different story to it the one
thing I would say that was important is
when you have to think about what the
path to scale is so a lot of time you do
the research because you're trying to
test an idea and you might learn
something and that's great but then you
have to say okay so now if we want to
see this change the world in some way
there's a there's a particular way of
asking this question that I stole from
Kevin Starr who have a head of the
Milagro Foundation which I like which is
to say who needs to do what differently
so you have to figure that out when you
have any sort of evidence you think
could actually be used okay
and when you want to start thinking
about how do you take something to scale
a stack
you know yourself so in this case when
you ask that you're looking at social
protection in the government because
you're really dealing something that
that is at scale and requires a lot of
money right
so this is this is really a government
so even though we these programs were
tested by nonprofits that was I we see
it as proof of concept and they were
they were actually operated at decent
scale so these are not tiny little
pilots that were that are you know small
and cozy cheating fairly large programs
but it takes another leap to go from
there to the entire country and for that
you need government the government needs
to be involved exactly the government
was involved in kind of observing the
results as they came out and along the
way and there were annual conferences in
which we were sharing early designs
early results things of this nature
so can you point to any countries who
really embraced the work that was done
and moved forward and created policy
around the finding so the two that stand
out so far I think we're up to about
eight million households now that have
been now part of this program after the
results came out that are now part of
government scale up um Ethiopia and
Pakistan in particular there are states
within India that are now expressing
interest in we're trying to start work
there but we've actually seen something
in the order of 25 to 35 different
conversations along the way in the
Philippines we've been talking with
doing something that's similar but not
exactly this and so one interesting
question then for them to figure out is
okay well what you're doing is similar
it's not this here's what's been tested
elsewhere maybe what you're doing
actually would work better but this is
where you know setting up a test would
really help them learn and so that's the
conversation the Philippines I'm heading
in two weeks to Guyana and the
government saw the results and reached
out to us and said how do we how can we
learn from this to set our policy so you
know we're seeing big countries and
small countries so were there any
surprises along the way and and I asked
this because I know you also just
published a book called failing in the
field and looks at some interesting case
studies of things not to do perhaps in
the field yep yeah this is a very
cathartic book for me to write I'm going
to like
so the you know it's it's it's almost
trite to say this but it's true we got
to learn from our failures right it's
it's fun to talk about the successes
there's no doubt I much prefer to go and
give a public talk and talk about this
program it feels great
it's exciting it's so but you know we
got to learn from the failures too
roughly speaking it's important to think
about three types of failures there's
idea failures implementation failures
and research failures
obviously there's probably a wider
category but in my space and my thinking
lr3 so an idea failure is when well it
turns out that was a good idea but it
didn't work
no so the idea was wrong something was
off the two that will focus on and
change your question our implementation
failures and research failures so in the
six sites one of them didn't work so
what I just told you was all excited I
didn't go through details we don't have
charts and stuff but if I did show you a
country-by-country you would see that
five of the sites looked really good and
one not so we actually saw a negative
effect it wasn't statistically
significant so I'll just call it zero
okay this was in Honduras the asset that
was provided were chickens and they got
sick and died in hindsight I think you
know I think it was a thought through
decision but I think one thing we
learned from that is you really we need
to really make sure that the assets that
are chosen to promote because you give
households choices in the way this
program runs but it's a constrained set
it's four choices and if it's something
new really make sure that it's good what
what are the one of the risks and
returns of that asset chickens can be
really profitable but also much riskier
and when a virus hits or some bug Hetson
yeah so it was a humanitarian failure
but we actually did learn something
important from it we learned the
importance of transferring that asset as
the linchpin of the program and if that
asset doesn't work if the program did
not work right a research failure and
this is what the book is about is when
no we didn't we didn't learn something
useful for the world about what to do
and what not to do we learned what not
to do as a researcher we learned that
you if you were going to set up a
randomized
in your code for randomization is flawed
you end up with a bad study and
sometimes that happens in a real Russian
you got to be careful we learned that if
you're doing a survey and you want to do
a test within your survey by reversing
the order of questions that this can be
really useful for learning but if you
screw up on the coding you screw up and
you don't get in so we did this we we
Anna Mize the ordering of questions
because we wanted to know if it mattered
and instead of randomizing the order we
actually just dropped half the questions
and it was just a coding error but you
know if we don't document these things
and point out that like look going to
electronic coding kit opens up some
doors but you got to be careful sure
there's some there are much more about
partner management failures where we
didn't really fully take into account
all the challenges that our partner was
going to face and so we were testing the
integration of a training program along
with a credit program but the credit
officers the training thing was this
thing on the side for them their
priority is getting repayments okay
and they weren't you even though senior
management said no no no we want to make
the training an important part they
didn't actually compensate the employees
with any sort of metrics for an outcomes
of actually doing the training instead
the compensation was all on a repayment
so what ended up happening was didn't
take long for any time any default to
happen or to be at risk of default the
credit offers just just stopped the
training and didn't do it right
so the whole the research just fell
apart and there's nothing to learn there
was no there's no report at the end of
the day there's no academic paper
there's no policy report we learned
nothing other than what not to do as a
research project and so that's been you
know we've had some successes but we've
also had a lot of those projects and we
need to document these and learn from
them so we wrote this book where we
collected a bunch of our stories and we
also have been working with the World
Bank development impact blog to post
stories on there so we're encouraging
people to try to do that as well are you
working at all with the UN and their
goals for sustainability so we have so I
mean IPA does have some projects I have
one project with them personally you
know with UNICEF that's a larger
institution in Ghana I don't know the
full slate of all the other projects the
sustainable developed
goals I think it's because you're
working on the poverty issue and I know
it's a huge UN issue so that's why I was
wondering if there's anyone out there
there's certainly a lot of overlap and
interest there's also a UN group called
better cap better better than cash
Alliance which would which is promote
trying to promote mobile money and we do
a lot of studies that are trying to
understand more about what the impact of
mobile money is as well as how to make
it work right I mean the micro financing
part of of giving people small loans and
having them well one of the things with
a with a with a self mobile money refers
to actually having effectively a bank
account via our cell phone and and
actually developing countries are some
of them are much further ahead the
United States on this so United States
we can use venmo or PayPal but but we
still have to fund those through a
credit card or a bank account in a
developing country particularly Kenya is
like the the poster child for can the
earliest launch an expansion of this
there is agents throughout the
throughout the country now where you can
just walk up give them cash and then it
basically gets deposited onto an account
and on your cell phone you can do a few
clicks and see that I have twelve
dollars and then I can send you the
twelve dollars nice and you might live
halfway across the country and so it's
an easy way for me to send you money
right the next the next phase that we're
seeing is a big push to say okay great
now that you can easily move money
around how about saving more let's make
it so you can automatic savings and then
the next step from that is now that you
you can actually get loans much more
easily in pay loans more easily so you
can lower the cost for banks for
reaching people and you can make it
really simple three clicks and you get
access to a loan that's actually a
really exciting opportunity in terms of
just lowering transaction costs three
clicks it's also a little scary yeah
three clicks we get alone like did you
really know the interest rate and all
the terms and how you're gonna repay
that you do how do you actually do
consumer protection and then disclosure
policy when it's three clicks and boom
you get a loan right so it's exciting
yeah but it also makes me nervous and so
there's a lot of work that needs to
happen
yeah front and the UN is the better
better at than cash alliance does work
on that areas as we do okay so moving
forward and looking at the future and
the graduation
program you know what do you see are you
building on that project absolutely
because we you know I feel like we we
really got over a big threshold I'm just
a kind of a proof of concept that there
is this theory of a poverty trap to a
lot of things and we can see impacts at
three years and we actually from the
India site we've seen positive results
at seven years we're gonna do long-term
follow-up on some of the others as well
but then there's a lot of questions that
we still don't know the answer to about
how to make this work better it cost is
a big issue it is an expensive program
so when you want to take this to a
country and try to work with them to
roll this out as a policy for the
country take the the weekly household
visits maybe there's a way of making
those monthly instead or you can take
them out can you still have the same
effect right I don't know but we can
test we can we can set up a study so
we're doing that in Ghana right now one
of the other lessons from the study that
was important is that even though the
the results created these big treatment
effects on average but some people were
helped a lot and other people just a
little bit mm-hmm so why and so we're
doing work to try to understand who has
helped a lot and who is given all of
these resources and then only really a
little bit better off what's going on
that they're not able to seize these
opportunities and run with them so in
Ghana we're set up a study where we are
rolling out cognitive behavioral therapy
to work on the issues of depression and
planning and and we're doing that before
the program just before the program and
then roll out the program and maybe that
will help households seize the
opportunity more and so then maybe we'll
see you know the households that we're
only being helped a little bit maybe
that'll help them seize this opportunity
and have a bigger bigger effect for them
so that's another test we'll we'll know
in a couple years the results so there's
lots of questions like this that are
important to know that are important
both for how to run the program better
how to run it at lower cost and and so
that's the kind of the next wave of the
agenda on these projects all right we
will look forward to hearing from you
about that then great thanks thank you
for being here with us - thank you very
much for sharing some of your work for
more information about Professor Carlin
and his research please visit our
website at macmillan yale.edu be sure to
join us again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Betty
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
[Music]
you